(marching music)
(triumphant music)
(slow drum beating)
(slow paced music)
- [Officer] Tanaka.
- [Soldier] Ho!
- Iuanaga.
- Here.
- Fugimoto.
- Yo!
- Mishi.
- Here!
- Uanaga!
- Here.
- Ataya!
- Yo!
- Sashi!
- Here!
- Olihamo!
- Yo!
- Komoto!
- Here!
(singing in foreign language)
- Kanakas.
The ones from Hawaii.
You know what they call us Mainlanders?
Kotonks.
The way they tell it,
if you rap on our heads,
it's like hitting a coconut.
Hollow heads, you know.
Kotonk, kotonk, kotonk.
- [Grayson] Look where
you're going, will ya?
- 90 day wonder.
Still got the original
shine on those bars.
- Lieutenant Grayson to see the adjutant.
- He's not in, sir.
The colonel said he'd see you himself.
- Thank you.
- You can go right in, sir.
Lieutenant Grayson reports for duty, sir.
- [Colonel] At ease, lieutenant.
Welcome to Camp Shelby.
- Thank you, sir.
- This your first assignment since
receiving your commission?
- Yes, sir.
- Well, lieutenant, it's a rough one.
The platoon you're taking over
is just ready to start training,
and as you may have noticed,
our facilities are not
all that they might be.
We're short of officers,
short of equipment,
short of everything except trainees,
and they're coming in by the carload.
This is a brand-new outfit.
A new kind of outfit.
No precedent for it except one battalion
that was activated in Hawaii
and they haven't been tested yet.
What do you think of the idea, lieutenant?
- Well, sir, I'd like to make a request.
- [Colonel] What is it?
- I'd like your permission, sir,
to put in for a transfer
to the 36th Division.
You see, sir, I'm from Texas--
- What has that got to do with it?
- Nothing, sir, except that the 36th
is an old Texas National Guard outfit,
and I've been in it ever
since I got in the Army.
That is, until they sent me to OCS.
I never would have gone if I'd thought.
Sir, I just took it for granted
that I'd go back to the 36th.
- You're sure that's the only reason
you have for wanting a transfer?
- [Grayson] Yes, sir.
- No objection to working with the kind
of troops we have here?
- Because they're Japs?
Oh, no, sir.
Nothing like that at all.
- Now, let's get a couple of
things straight, lieutenant.
First, there's not gonna be any transfer.
You're staying here.
Have you got that?
- [Grayson] Yes, sir.
- Second, they're not Japs.
They're Japanese Americans.
Nisei or, as they call
themselves, buddhaheads.
All kinds of buddhaheads, lieutenant.
From Hawaii, Alaska, California,
New York, Colorado.
Yes, and even some from Texas.
They're all American citizens,
and they're all volunteers.
Remember that.
And another thing.
We officers are referred
to as haoles not white men.
Any questions?
- No, sir.
- Report to your company commander.
The sergeant major will show
you to his orderly room.
That'll be all, lieutenant.
(singing in foreign language)
- Sorry to keep you waiting, lieutenant.
- Oh, Captain Solari.
- That's right.
That's our regimental slogan.
- "Go for broke"?
- It's Pidgin English for shoot the works.
Pull up a chair, lieutenant.
- Nice.
- I'll be with you in a minute.
- Tell me, sir,
do you use live ammunition
in the rifle range?
- A Jap's a Jap, eh?
- All I know is they were
put under armed guard
in relocation centers last year.
Maybe the Army just had
some surplus barbed wire
they wanted to use up, was that it?
- The Army was facing an emergency
at the start of the war.
A possible invasion by Japanese troops.
So all Japanese Americans were evacuated
from the West Coast.
There was no loyalty check,
no screening, nothing.
If there were any spies among them,
I can assure you they're not in the 442.
Every man in this outfit
has been investigated,
reinvestigated, and re-reinvestigated.
Now, I suggest you start
getting acquainted.
Your platoon sergeant's
over in the supply room.
Ohhara.
- Ohhara!
- That's right.
Takashi Ohhara.
- Hey, wait a minute.
Come back here.
How long you been in the Army, soldier?
- Let me see now.
Maybe I been inside, two, three months.
How long you been inside, lieutenant?
- Don't you know you're
supposed to hold your salute
till an officer returns it?
- Oh, sure.
Sometime forget.
- [Grayson] "Sometime forget"
to say sir, too, don't ya?
- Sometime.
- [Grayson] Well, don't forget it anymore.
- No, sir.
- That's your own uniform?
- [Tommy] Sir, that's
the smallest size he got,
the supply sergeant, Sir.
- Well, roll those sleeves down.
- I hold salute, sir.
- Why are you wearing leggings
with a class A uniform?
- To keep my pants up, sir.
Long like that.
- Well, get 'em cut down.
- Oh, yes, sir.
Payday I'll go see the tailor, sir.
- You'd better see somebody today
before I see you again.
(singing in foreign language)
- [Man] All right, men.
All I wanna see is backbones and elbows.
- Come on.
And he made it.
Little Phoebe.
Pretty little Phoebe.
Watch that stuff, huh?
Get your money down, suckers.
It all rides.
Go for broke.
- Gee, break 'em up, break 'em up!
New lieutenant outside.
Must be the one for us.
Oh, boy.
Eight feet tall and mean like anything.
Number-one manini kind.
Chicken.
- Well, the honeymoon's over.
- Mix me up.
All Nisei outfit.
How come haole officers?
- That's just to make us
a little more miserable.
First, they pick out the crummiest camp
in the United States.
- Why'd you ever enlist?
That's what I wanna know.
- Why?
Because a wise guy college man like you
snowed me under with a lot of fancy talk.
You guys from relocation centers.
Okay, you probably got it better here.
But me, I was on the outside.
Iowa.
A free man knocking off 500 bucks a month.
- 500 bucks?
No.
- 500 buck, yeah.
Chick sexing.
I can look at a day-old chick
and tell you if it's a he or a she.
(man laughing)
- Now, who'd want to know
that except another chick?
- You pay for the poultry feed
and you'd wanna know.
A he ain't no good at
all when it grows up.
Only the shes.
- How come chicken farmers
no can find out themselves?
Too bashful?
- You funny man.
Chick sexing is a science.
It was developed in Japan,
and it's one field where
buddhahead gets a break.
Mean to say ya never heard of it?
- I just got as far as
the birds and the bees.
- These college guys are
sharp, you know that?
(cat meowing)
Four years at USC and he's a bonafide,
recognized fruit peddler.
Yes, sir.
A fruit peddler with
an architect's degree.
- I could have got a job as
an architect if I kept trying.
- Well, why didn't you?
- It's just my eyes.
Couldn't handle all that close work.
- Yeah, eye trouble, that's what it was.
All you need is corrective glasses
to take the slant out of your eyes.
- Ah, chick, chick, chick, chick, chick,
chick, chick, chick, chick, chick.
- Hey, kotonk.
Take it easy, huh?
Huh, Chick?
- Come on, get it down.
Buck and a half.
One more, one more.
- Boy, oh, boy!
You one lucky kotonk.
Wish I got packages like that.
- You and me both.
- You send package?
- Yeah, hand me those cans, will you?
- Where you gonna send?
Brother in the Army in Pacific?
- Uh-uh.
Family in a relocation camp in Arizona.
Arizona, U.S.A.
You think that chow here is bad, brother.
- You can even get soap?
- Oh, sure.
They've got a canteen loaded with stuff.
Anything you want,
if you can get there
before they're sold out.
Yes, sir, all the comforts of home.
And only one block from the barracks
to the toilets and showers.
- Barracks?
Everybody all thrown together?
- Got partitions.
Separate room for each family.
My folks are lucky.
Only five of them since I left.
- Treat you like that,
hard to figure why a guy
volunteer for the Army.
- We have to do something,
so we never get a deal like that again.
- We show 'em.
We show 'em us buddhaheads
good soldiers, good Americans.
- That's the idea.
I hope it works.
- Sure it works.
Already a lot of stuff in
newspapers about the 442.
- Yeah, all we need now is casualty lists.
- [Tommy] Gee, that's a pretty girl.
What her name?
- Terry.
Nice name.
Your wife?
- Not yet.
- [Tommy] Why you wait?
- This is a great time to be
starting a family, isn't it?
- [Tommy] You kotonks, funny guys.
Boy, if I had a girl like that,
they gotta draft me.
No volunteer.
No, sir, draft me and drag me away.
- Once more, once more.
Go for broke!
Once more, that's all I ask.
That's all!
Seven!
- Let me see those dice!
- Attention!
(cat meows)
- At ease.
- Men, this is Lieutenant
Grayson, our platoon leader.
- Pick up that money.
Pick it up.
- Yes, sir.
- Donation for the company fund, sergeant.
Give it to Sergeant Ohhara.
- [Chick] Can he do that?
It's my money.
- I want that man's name, sergeant.
There's no talking after
the command at ease.
- Yes, sir.
- This man, no dog tags,
needs haircut, window unwashed,
uniforms hanging wrong way.
Haircut, shave, bunk
out of line, dog tags,
window, beer can on shelf,
dirty floor, dirty boots,
haircut, window,
bowl of milk on floor.
Bowl stolen from mess hall.
Brought cat into barracks.
Floor, boots, dog tag, haircut.
Dust on rafters, window,
haircut, dog tags, boots,
bunk out of line,
litter on floor, boots.
Forget the book, sergeant.
They're all on the list.
You men will fall out for a speed hike
at eight o'clock tonight.
Before that I want this hutment GI'd.
Get them started on it
right away, sergeant.
Floors scrubbed, rafters dusted,
windows washed, boots shined, bunks made.
I want those blankets stretched so tight
that when you drop a quarter
on them it'll bounce.
I'll be back twice a day from now on
with a pair of white gloves and a quarter.
(door slams)
- You're a chicken expert.
What do you make of him?
(rock clanking)
♪ I wanna go back ♪
♪ To my little grass shack ♪
♪ Back in Kealakekua ♪
♪ Hawaii ♪
♪ I wanna be with all ♪
♪ The kanes and wahines ♪
♪ That I knew long ago ♪
♪ I can hear ♪
♪ The old guitars playing ♪
(speaking foreign language)
(ukulele strums)
(determined music)
(speaking foreign language)
- What did he say?
- I didn't hear anything, sir.
(speaking foreign language)
- What does that mean?
- Sorry, sir.
I don't speak Japanese.
- Boots, dog tag, window,
dust on rafters, floor, boots.
(water splashing)
Boots, floor, boots.
Blankets not tight enough.
Shirt unbuttoned, boots, window, floor.
(triumphant music)
(tense music)
(wood thudding)
All right, up and over!
Go back and try it again!
I'm gonna wait right here
till everybody makes it.
- [Soldier On Top] Hey,
you guys, beat it, quick!
(perky music)
- In combat, anything goes.
That's why we teach you dirty tactics.
I will now demonstrate
a grip against which
there is absolutely no defense.
The sergeant will now try to get free.
Well, sergeant?
- You want me to try, sir?
- Of course I want you to try.
- Very well, sir.
(triumphant music)
- Eyes right!
Eyes front!
Eyes right!
- That was the kiss of death, brother,
the kiss of death.
- Yeah, the big brass figures were ripe.
I can smell that salt air already.
- Take another sniff, will ya,
and see if it's the Pacific.
- Yeah, that's what I'm sweating out.
- You and me both.
- Nobody wanna go Pacific but me.
Well, I keep trying.
Every time they ask for volunteers--
- Tommy, you have to
speak perfect Japanese.
It's for combat
intelligence, interpreters.
They don't want buddhahead
riflemen in the Pacific.
- Why?
- Look, Tommy, a million
guys fighting an enemy
that looks like us.
What if a GI sniper spots you or me?
- He see uniform.
- Yeah, and probably figure we're spies.
- Sam, I tell you something.
I don't like talk about it,
but I'm gonna tell you.
Pearl Harbor day the planes they come.
You can only read it.
I can see it.
Pretty soon, I go volunteer
for the 100th Battalion.
Too young.
By the 442 come up, I volunteer again.
Too small.
Next time, I stand on
my toes a little bit.
Okay, I'm in.
They send us Europe.
Sure, I go and fight.
More better do I fight
the ones who bomb the islands.
- It's the same enemy, Tommy.
- Maybe for you.
Pearl Harbor day, two people
visit friends near Honolulu.
They both been killed.
My mother, Sam.
My father.
- [Man] Mail call!
(men chattering)
Guchizaki.
- Right here, right here!
- Hey, this is from my brother
in the 100th Battalion!
- [Mail Clerk] Nawaguchi.
- Mail call, Tommy.
- Come on, hurry up!
- [Tommy] You go.
No mail for Tommy.
(triumphant music)
- Come on, close it up, close it up.
- Here's the list, lieutenant.
- Thanks, captain.
Nagashook, Shooki.
- [Soldier] William J.
- Nishigoka.
- [Soldier] Leonard S.
- Uchigakiuchi.
- [Soldier] Harry.
- Ikagani.
- [Soldier] Joseph T.
- Kamakura.
- [Soldier] Sam W.
- Toyotomi.
- Tomatsu.
- [Lieutenant] Guchizaki.
- Satoshi.
- Shimabukarotenshugi.
- Shima...
- Shima--
- [Soldier] George W.
- Thanks.
Fugimoto.
- [Soldier] Thomas H.
(metal clanking)
- Any scuttlebutt on where
this scow is taking us?
- I was just gonna ask you, lieutenant.
♪ Aloha ♪
♪ I'm sending ♪
♪ My thoughts ♪
♪ Back home to you ♪
Hey, Sam, how you know so sure
we're going to England?
- Because that's where the line forms
for the invasion of France.
And it's coming off any day now.
- That's us, shock troops.
Just in time.
They used up the 100th
Battalion at Cassino.
- But anyway, it won't be the Pacific.
- How do you know?
You ever hear of the Panama Canal?
- Hey, Sam, what you think?
Maybe so, huh?
- Well, if it's the Pacific,
we've been sailing three
days in the wrong direction.
- The navigator don't know.
Nobody knows.
Drives you nuts.
- [Grayson] Oh, I'll get it.
- Thank you, lieutenant.
(tense music)
- [Grayson] For 20
years the Italian people
have been fed on bunk.
Their propagandists declared
that all of our people
look upon Italians with contempt,
regarding them as a race of hand organ men
and banana peddlers.
We know that such statements are lies.
Racial prejudice is abhorrent
to our American concept of democracy.
(slow paced ukulele)
Naples with its old world
history, majestic Vesuvius,
the Castle of St. Elmo,
the famous churches,
the magnificent harbor,
second to none in all the world.
These and many other historic sights
are of interest to the soldier.
Take advantage of this opportunity.
See as much as you can.
You've got a great chance to do now,
major expenses paid, what would cost you
a lot of your own money after the war.
You'll want to poke around in quaint,
out-of-the way places
and the only way to do that is to walk.
Be sure to allow plenty of time in Naples
so you can take it all in
at a nice leisurely pace.
Start your promenade at the harbor.
The Italian practice is
to have a siesta hour
sometime between one and four
o'clock in the afternoon.
If this custom remains in vogue
during occupational period,
you'll save time and patience
by confining your shopping to other hours.
(people chattering)
- Mama, Mama, (speaking foreign language).
- Come on, come on, don't hog it all.
- Let's go!
Off your seat and on your feet!
- [Grayson] Continuing our
tour of picturesque Italy,
we come to the Via Casilina,
which leads directly to Rome.
The districts around
Rome are full of places
of historical interests,
and transportation is excellent.
- [Man] Take a break!
- [Man] Take 10!
(vehicle approaching)
- Everybody rides but the buddhaheads.
(singing in foreign language)
- That's the 100th Battalion!
Masami!
Hey, Masami!
- Hi, you paisan!
- My brother.
Him okay?
- Not even a scratch.
He's a few trucks back!
Hey, haven't got an extra
top string, have you?
- I don't think so.
Where you going?
- Same place as you, paisan.
Haven't you heard?
We been attached to the 442.
One big, happy family!
- No kidding!
Ride on, boy.
Here, top string!
(speaking in foreign language)
- What was that?
- I said very sorry.
Sorry, sir.
(slow gentle music)
- [Grayson] Within easy reach of Rome,
are the medieval towns of Tuscany,
sleepy little villages,
scarcely touched by the
march of civilization.
(bomb rumbling)
Take 10!
- Hello, Joe.
(speaking foreign language)
- No, but I'd like to learn.
The door open?
The door, the door.
- It's open, lieutenant.
(speaking foreign language)
- The lady is gonna mend this for me.
Call me when the word
comes down to move out.
- Yes, sir.
♪ The eyes of Texas are upon you ♪
♪ All the livelong day-- ♪
(window slams)
- You know, I got a hunch we're
coming into a bottle of vino.
- Maybe.
- Yeah, I just got a
feeling the lieutenant's
gonna take care of us.
(vehicle approaching)
(bombs exploding)
(boy speaking foreign language)
- Break's over!
- [Soldier] Let's go!
- [Soldier] All right, on your feet!
(canons firing)
- Lieutenant Grayson.
I forgot to tell him we're moving out.
- Holy mackerel.
- What'll I do?
- [Officer] Close it up!
(slow paced music)
(woman laughing)
(speaking foreign language)
- Come again, (speaking foreign language)
- Friend.
- No, I don't know him.
Your friend, huh?
(speaking foreign language)
Smith.
John Smith.
Capitano, John Smith.
- Glad to meet ya, sir.
(speaking foreign language)
Don't tell me where you got
that good-conduct ribbon.
Let me guess.
(speaking foreign language)
How about some more vino, huh?
Darling.
(perky music)
- That's my old outfit!
Where did you get this?
Who gave it to you?
- John Smith.
- John Smith, huh?
Is he still around here?
When did you see him last?
(speaking foreign language)
I gotta find somebody
who can talk English.
I'll be right back!
- Joe!
Joe!
- [Soldier] Grayson.
Your platoon's dug in over there.
Come here a minute, will ya?
I've got a message for
ya from the colonel.
He was up here inspecting our positions.
- The colonel?
- That's right.
He said to tell you he
was particularly pleased
with the way your platoon was deployed.
- Thanks for covering up.
- [Man On Mound] And now I'm
supposed to say you're welcome
and that's that until the next time, huh?
- There won't be any next time.
Don't worry about that.
- I'll tell ya when to leave.
You're such a stickler on
military courtesy for your men.
From now on, you and I are going
by the book, understand?
- Yes, sir.
- I don't mind telling you, Grayson,
if there was any chance of
getting a replacement for you
I'd have had you court-martialed for this.
Ever since you joined the outfit,
you've been the one man in this
company who's been out of step!
You'd better pick it up, lieutenant,
and pick it up fast,
or you're gonna find yourself volunteering
for every dirty detail that comes up!
Is that clear?
- Yes, sir.
- [Officer On Mound] That'll be all.
♪ It wasn't the moon above ♪
- Did you do a good job, lieutenant?
♪ That made me fall in love ♪
♪ It was just those eyes ♪
♪ Those beautiful eyes ♪
- Where's Kamakura?
- Sam?
Out looking for water, lieutenant.
How do you like that?
Dying of thirst in the middle of a river.
- I wanna see him the minute he gets back.
- Yes, sir.
(metal clanking)
- [Masami] Hiya, paisan!
- Masami!
Eddie!
- Vino, fresh off the vine!
Salute.
- Good, eh, paisan?
(speaking foreign language)
- Free sample.
- Thanks.
(guns firing)
- Eddie!
Eddie!
- You stay here, Tommy, watch us!
Come on, keep close to the wall!
(guns firing)
(metal clanking)
Stay here, one at a time.
(speaking foreign language)
(gun clicking)
(gun firing)
(men screaming)
(bomb exploding)
- Anybody home?
Keep me covered.
You okay, Masami?
- Just a scratch.
(pig snorting)
- Jerry intelligence officer.
They're great at disguises.
- Hiya, paisan.
(pig snorting)
(bombs exploding)
(chandelier clanking)
- Shells would be coming in a lot closer
if those Jerries were still
in that observation post.
One of them was an officer you say?
- Oh, yes, colonel, sir.
- Well, you certainly earned that.
Take this over to S2, sergeant.
- Yes, sir.
- Too bad about that 100th Battalion man.
What'd they say at the aid station
about the other one who was wounded?
- Million-dollar wound, sir.
They're sending him back to Rome.
- Good.
Well, anytime you're in
the neighborhood, drop in.
- Thank you, sir.
- I mean that.
I wanna keep in close touch
with you men on the line.
They been treatin' you all right?
- [Both] Yes, sir.
- You're sure now, no complaints?
- No, sir.
- Well, good luck to you.
- Sir, could I have a word with you?
- Well, of course.
At ease, lieutenant.
- You remember, sir,
that I told you I came
from the 36th Division?
- I remember it very well.
- Well, sir, I just
happened to hear that the
36th is somewhere in this area.
- Was, lieutenant, they're
way up ahead of us now.
- Oh.
Oh, well, in that case, sir--
- Still like to get back
in the Texas Army, eh?
- Oh no sir, I was just hoping
I'd get a chance to visit them.
- Well, I'll do better than that.
If we ever meet up with the 36th,
I'll try and work out a transfer.
- Oh, thank you very much, sir.
- Not at all, it'll be a pleasure.
That'll be all, lieutenant.
(chandelier clanking)
(pig snorting)
- It's all right, paisan.
Maybe he know we scared too, huh?
- Gives a man a nice feeling
knowing you can always go to the old man
if you're not gettin' a
fair shake, huh, lieutenant?
Sir, I feel bad about
forgettin' to call you
when we moved out of
that town this afternoon.
Look, you see the way it happened--
- Forget it, forget it.
- I can't.
It was all my fault.
And they might have had
you up for desertion.
But, it'll never get out.
The men'll keep it quiet.
I'll see to that, sir.
- Thanks, thanks.
(engine chugging)
(pig squealing)
(gun firing)
- Squad leaders, up front.
(guns firing)
- Are you from the 100th Battalion?
- Yeah.
- What happens when a man gets hit?
(gun firing)
(soldier screaming)
- Sometimes they yell.
(gun firing)
Sometimes they don't.
Squad leaders don't last long.
- I mean the medics.
How do they get to you?
Medics! Medics!
- Get on the other side of the road!
Hit it!
(guns firing)
- Let's go, boy.
(tense music)
(guns firing)
(bombs exploding)
- [Soldier] Squad leaders up front.
- Squad leaders up front.
- What are you waiting for, sergeant?
- I forgot.
(tense music)
(guns firing)
(pig squealing)
(speaking foreign language)
(bomb exploding)
(triumphant music)
- Hey, you'd better move, Sam.
Maybe he gonna shake.
- Have a good time, Frank.
- How can I miss?
Rome, the greatest
architecture in the world.
24-hour passes.
Big-hearted, ain't they?
- I'm gonna see a lot of
things in the next 24 hours
I've dreamed about all my life.
The Forum, Saint Peter's, the Pantheon--
- Any other outfit, I bet
they get three-day passes.
Yeah, and not just one
man at a time, either.
- Ah, chick, chick, chick,
chick, chick, chick, chick.
- Relax.
That reminds me, Tommy,
I hear we're having chicken for dinner.
- [Tommy] No joke?
- Yeah, I was talking to one of the cooks.
Fried chicken.
- Good, boy.
That's what I like best.
- Not me.
You know what I like best?
Barbecued pork, yes, sir.
There's nothing like barbecued pork.
Especially the way I make it.
(pig squeals)
- Mail call!
Jingu.
(men shouting)
Hitrai.
Gutsizaki.
Mishima.
- [Soldier] Here! Here!
- [Mail Clerk] Kawaquichi.
(pig squeals)
(speaking foreign language)
- You like-a vino, Joe?
- Ah, no, he no for sale.
(speaking foreign language)
- Three bottles, Joe.
- Not for nothin'.
(speaking foreign language)
Waste time.
Come on, paisan.
(speaking foreign language)
- Family, family.
- Hungry, hungry.
- Okay, plenty meat on her.
(speaking foreign language)
- No eat, no eat.
- Oh, no, no.
(speaking foreign language)
(hums "Wedding March")
Papa, Mama.
(speaking foreign language)
- Oh.
Paisan, him kind of young for papa, no?
(speaking foreign language)
- We wait.
Three months.
(speaking foreign language)
Nine bottles, 10!
- No!
- No, Papa.
- Hey, Tommy!
Look what I got.
Cookies.
Here, help yourself.
Paisan too.
- He no like cookies.
Maybe bambinos, eh?
- Sure, go ahead.
- Who that from, Sam?
Your mother?
- Terry.
Hey, remember that town we took?
Suvereto?
It was on a news
broadcast, coast to coast,
and they mentioned the 442.
- No kidding?
- I'm tellin' you.
And there've been newspaper
stories, lots of 'em.
The 100th is getting the
Presidential Citation
from General Mark Clark,
Sassetta, Hill 140.
- Hey.
Let me see that.
How you like that?
They gonna let your kid brother
leave relocation camp and work on a farm.
Next month he gonna pick
sugar beets in Idaho.
- Well, what do ya know.
He's been trying to swing
that deal for months.
- Good boy.
All okay, nobody sick.
Oh, oh, excuse, Sam.
- That's okay.
I'll read the rest to you.
- "Honestly, Sam, you'd hardly
recognize the old homestead.
"Maybe it looks the same, the
barracks, the barbed wire,
"the MPs, but it isn't the same anymore.
"Nothing's the same.
"Because everybody knows
what the 442 is doing.
"And what means most to me is the change
"in the kids in my class."
She teaches in camp school.
- I know, I know, first grade.
- "They were such sad little
people, never laughed,
"never made a sound.
"Today, I'm happy to say,
I have as noisy a classroom
"as you'll find in America."
- More better now, eh, kotonk?
- Looks that way, Kanaka.
Plenty better now.
"I miss you so very much, my darling.
"I can't find words to tell you
"how dear you are to me."
(singing in foreign language)
(shouting in foreign language)
- How was it?
How was Rome?
I'll see you tomorrow!
I gotta go to the C.P.
and pick up my pass!
- [Man] End of the line, everybody out.
(men chattering)
- Just wanted to let you
know we're back, sir.
- Oh, good.
You're just in time.
- Oh, thanks.
- Sergeant, have the driver report
to the motor pool, will ya?
- Yes, sir.
- He's got a full tank, sir.
All set to go with the next batch.
- I was all set to go too.
Change of orders, we're
going back on the line.
- That's kind of rough.
Somebody was telling me
your folks came from Rome.
- A little town near there.
Oh, well, I'll get to see it someday.
- Sure you will.
- Hey, we met up with some of your
folks while you were gone.
Your old outfit.
- The 36th!
- They passed us on their way back.
The Texas Wonders had all they could take
so they called in the 442.
- Where'd they go?
- The word is they're being moved
to another theater of operations.
- Is that straight?
- Looks like you're stuck with us
for the rest of the war.
- Guy gets in to fight the Japs
and winds up fightin' with 'em.
It's a hot one when you
come to think of it.
- Oh, I don't know.
A lot of us have parents who
were born in enemy countries.
Italian Americans, German Americans--
- That's different, sir, and you know it.
- Why?
- Well, it's just--
- The shape of their eyes?
Or is it the color of their skin?
- Tell the truth, sir,
wouldn't you rather be
with some other outfit?
- If I knew of a better
outfit, but I don't.
- Will that be all, sir?
- [Colonel] You don't
have to be so formal.
- It was your idea to go by the book.
- That was a long time ago.
- I'll see ya later.
- How was it, lieutenant?
- [Grayson] Great!
(bombs exploding)
- I hope the supply sergeant
takes good care of your pig.
Yep, I sure hope he feeds
him good so he'll be nice
and fat when we get back off the line.
- Hey, Frank, look!
Look at that!
- Must be an old Roman villa.
Yeah, you can tell it's
Roman by those columns.
(guns firing)
- Rubble from another war, huh?
- It's hard to believe.
Over 2000 years old.
- The battles that must have
been fought around here.
Napoleon, Charlemagne, Caesar,
Alexander the Great,
all the way back to biblical times.
- More better we fight
like biblical times.
I read in the Bible.
Your army pick number one man,
enemy pick number one man,
and by big fight, two men,
one killed, war over.
- I nominate Lieutenant
Grayson for our side.
- No, I wouldn't know who to root for.
(shouting in foreign language)
- It's some kind of
headquarters all right,
and it looks like they're
gettin' ready to pull out.
(guns firing)
- Yeah, with all their maps and records.
And one machine gun's holding us back.
(machine whooshing)
A little more to the right!
30 yards!
- Got any more?
Be right back.
- [Soldier] 30 yards to
the right, can you hear me?
- [Man Loading Weapon] Yeah, how's this?
(bomb exploding)
- Come on, let's take a walk.
Hey, you over there!
(guns firing)
Not you!
(bomb exploding)
You take over, Ohhara.
(shouting in foreign language)
(guns firing)
(bomb exploding)
Keep firing that mortar!
Keep it going!
Where's that mortar?
(bomb exploding)
(guns firing)
- I don't think these columns'll
be here for the next war.
- [Soldier] How about that mortar?
- [Tommy] Right away!
I gotta move it!
- [Soldier] Hurry up with that mortar!
- [Tommy] Okay, okay!
- They moved the gun!
- Right, 50 yards right!
- Short! Short!
Give it another 50 yards!
Now over to the left, just a little!
That's it!
Pour it on!
(shouting foreign language)
- Hold it! Hold it!
Cease-fire!
Let's go!
(shouting foreign language)
(guns firing)
- What kind of troops are these?
Chinese?
- Japanese.
Didn't Hitler tell ya?
Japan surrendered and they're
fighting on our side now.
- Well, it beats walking.
- Maybe walking through
Italy wasn't so bad.
Didn't you get the latest latrinogram?
We're shipping out.
- Shipping out?
- And so we take leave of sunny Italy
and sail the seven seas to--
- To where?
- My guess is the Pacific.
- You really think so, lieutenant?
- Yeah, but don't worry about it.
I haven't guessed right once
since I've been in the Army.
- Watch that stuff!
- Sorry.
(slow guitar strumming)
- Tommy!
(pig snorts)
- Oh, hello, lieutenant.
- I told you to go easy on that leg.
- [Tommy] Plenty okay now, lieutenant.
- Well, what did you
leave the hospital for?
- I've been still, lieutenant.
Three weeks.
Long time, sir.
- Don't you realize
officially you're AWOL?
I don't know whether to put
you in for a Silver Star
or have you court-martialed.
- Gotta leave hospital, sir.
Big rumor, 442 going Pacific.
Me plenty sad sack get left behind, huh?
Sir, maybe we still gonna fight Japan.
You think so, maybe?
- No, Tommy.
It's definitely France.
(pig snorting)
(Tommy coughs)
- It's bad cough.
I catch him in a hospital.
(pig snorting)
(Tommy coughs)
More better now, sea air good.
(pig snorting)
(Tommy coughs)
Well, goodbye, lieutenant.
(pig squealing)
(Tommy coughs)
- Goodbye, Tommy.
You are about to play a personal part
in pushing the Germans out of France.
Just west of the Riviera
district in southern France
lies the port of Marseilles.
You will be fortunate indeed
if you are stationed in
this fascinating city.
However, the chances are
you will be located in the provinces.
Rooms with private bath are still deluxe
in provincial towns, and you
won't always have steam heat,
but there are many compensations.
For instance, your
breakfast will be brought
to your bedroom without extra charge.
(slow gentle music)
(pig snorting)
(train horn whistles)
First class on French trains
ranks with our extra-fare trains,
second ranks with our parlor car
and third class is like
our ordinary-day coach.
If French coaches are less
comfortable than ours,
remember that they are
also less expensive.
It all evens up.
- Who's got the time?
- 2:20 sir.
- Thanks.
- Who do you think that I
oughta see about it, sir?
- S1 personnel.
They assign the new replacements,
but they're not gonna put two
brothers in the same platoon.
- My kid brother's got
a way with him, sir,
and he's just liable to talk them into it.
- Bad enough being in the same regiment,
but the same platoon...
- Yeah, I'd hate for my
folks to get two telegrams
from the War Department on the same day.
(cart clanking)
- Where are you going?
- Think I'll ride with my platoon, sir.
- You're overdoing the
"sir" business, lieutenant.
- I keep forgetting.
And here I've been an officer
for two hours and 20 minutes.
(men laughing)
How are you doing, Grayson?
(horn blowing)
(singing in foreign language)
- Hey, Sam, you think Terry okay?
- Sure, it was just a little cold.
- I feel more better
when the mail catch up.
Long time he no get mail.
- I wonder how my brother's making out.
- Me too.
I guess he work on the sugar-beet farm
already two, three weeks.
Hey, Ohhara, we want the mail!
- [Ohhara] Write your congressman.
10-hut!
(men chattering)
As you were.
Carry on, men.
- How do you like that?
Do they give a commission
to one of us buddhaheads?
No, they give it to the mick.
- Ohhara, the fighting Irishman.
- Faith, and you can say that again.
Now, get along with your blarney.
I've got something to tell you.
- At ease!
At ease!
Let's be having a little
military courtesy.
Yes, sir.
- I haven't been assigned yet,
but it looks like I'll be
taking over another platoon.
I probably won't be
seeing much of you guys.
I just wanted to say, well, so long.
- He gonna make good platoon leader.
- Yeah, while he lasts.
He's welcome to them bars.
- Sam, look at those buildings!
17th century!
- [Sam] I'm looking at that bakery.
- Go ahead, Tommy.
I'll keep an eye on the pig.
- Stick close to the train, you guys.
I'm tired of rounding up stragglers.
(speaking foreign language)
What'd he say?
- Oh, that's Japanese for thank you.
They're very polite.
♪ The eyes of Texas are upon you ♪
♪ All the livelong day ♪
♪ You cannot get away ♪
♪ Do not think you can escape them ♪
♪ I tried so early in the morn ♪
♪ The eyes of Texas are upon you ♪
- Pardon me.
Pardon me!
- Hello, baby.
- When did you learn that song?
- When?
- That's right, when did you learn it?
- Learn what?
- The song, song!
♪ The eyes of Texas are upon you ♪
(speaking foreign language)
♪ All the livelong day ♪
- No, no, no!
When you learn song?
- Ah, last week.
Soldiers.
- 36th Division?
- I think so.
Big T.
- Are they still here?
No, packed yesterday.
(horn blowing)
(speaking foreign language)
(women laughing)
- Well, well, the ambassador from Texas.
- Good afternoon, sir.
- You know, lieutenant, I had
you down as a determined man,
but I didn't think you had enough drag
to get the whole darned outfit
transferred to the 36th.
- Transferred?
- That's right, lieutenant.
We've been attached to the 36th Division.
I guess that makes us honorary Texans.
- Well, fan my brow.
Keep an eye out for
cattle-rustlers, partner.
- Well, what do you know about that?
- I thought you'd be pleased, lieutenant.
This is the man we've
been looking for, major.
One of the new combat
commissions to replace him.
- Well, there's one in
his platoon sir, Ohhara.
- Good, he can take over.
- Take over my platoon, sir?
- We've had a request
for a liaison officer
to work out of 36th headquarters.
Someone who can get along with them
and knows the 442 thoroughly.
- But, sir, I've always been on the line.
Do you think I have the qualifications
for a headquarter's job?
- I think you'll make good.
When a man wants anything as
badly as you've wanted this.
- But sir, I don't want this.
Remember, I told you I
just wanted to visit them.
I've got a lot of friends in the 36th.
- None of them at headquarters, I take it.
(horn blowing)
Sorry I couldn't arrange to have you
sent back to your platoon.
- Colonel Pence--
- Your orders will be issued immediately!
- All aboard!
Texas special!
Dallas, Forth Worth, Galveston,
Houston and all points south.
Yeah, man!
- Ya-hoo!
(speaking foreign language)
- [Man] Don't forget to write.
(machines blowing)
- How do you like that
Texas artillery, strangers?
- Stranger?
Man, I'm from Texas myself.
- Well, pull up a chair
and have a mint julep.
- That's mighty neighborly, friend,
but we're heading back towards town.
Another posse's gonna spell us for a bit.
Tommy's sure anxious to
get back to that town
where he left Paisan.
- Ain't love wonderful?
- Howdy, stranger!
- Aloha.
- There's only one thing I don't
like about these buddhaheads.
They don't dig 'em long enough.
- Hello, my friend!
He's here, the little Paisan.
He's here.
- Paisan.
Hello, Paisan.
You looking good, boy.
You're looking wonderful, Paisan.
Come on, Paisan.
You're beautiful, Paisan.
(Paisan squeals)
- Nice pig.
He miss you much.
- I miss him too.
Oh, thanks for taking care of him.
Thanks a lot.
- Thank you.
You are very kind.
- What's the matter?
You don't smoke?
- Yes, I smoke.
I was hoping maybe something
to eat for the children.
Chocolate, crackers, anything.
They have so little, so little to eat.
- I don't have anything to eat.
Trade the cigarettes.
Two packs.
You can get a couple of chickens for that.
- Not here.
No chickens left.
Nothing.
- All right.
I'll come back later.
- I hate to ask.
- It won't be much.
All we get is K rations.
- It will be a feast for them.
I wish I could get something better.
Well, see you later.
- [Man] Goodbye, my friend.
(baby crying)
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
How wonderful for the children.
(speaking foreign language)
(Paisan squealing)
(singing in foreign language)
- Kanakas.
The ones from Hawaii.
Let's stop a minute, huh?
I won't be long.
- [Soldier] Throw those bums out!
Yeah, go on, get up there.
- No, they're doing fine!
Come on, hula-hula, Kaz.
- Kaz!
- Hey!
(everyone shouting)
(singing in foreign language)
(Culley laughing)
- [Woman] Would you like some wine?
(speaking foreign language)
- These men, the little ones,
they are really Japanese?
- Hey, shorty, she wants
to know if you're Japanese.
I guess we can let her in on it, huh?
They're our new secret weapon.
Twilight fighters.
- Twilight fighters?
- Yeah.
The Army gives them shots
to make them turn yellow, see.
They send them out in the evening,
just as the sun's going down.
The enemy can't see 'em in that light.
Get the idea?
- That guy's been looking
for trouble all night.
If he makes one more crack, I'll--
- [Grayson] Tommy!
How are you?
- Lieutenant Grayson!
- [Grayson] How's the leg?
- Fit like a fiddle.
- Hiya, fellas.
- Howdy, Grayson.
- [Grayson] Say, who's your friend,
the one with all the stripes?
- [Sam] They don't care who they make
platoon sergeant anymore.
- How about having a
refill with us lieutenant?
- Thanks Frank, I wanna
say hello to somebody,
my old platoon sergeant.
I trained under him.
Be right back.
Culley!
- Grayson!
- [Grayson] How are you?
- Lieutenant Grayson.
- [Grayson] Yeah, how about that?
- How about a drink?
- [Grayson] Great, great.
Come on, there's room down here.
- That guy would be a buddy of Grayson's.
- Five to one he don't
come back for that drink.
- [Sam] Get it up.
- They tell me you really got it made.
What is this liaison racket?
- Oh, it varies, from a soft snap
to an extra soft snap.
Thank you.
Tomorrow I'm moving out with you.
How do you like that?
Back with the old platoon.
- You mean, I gotta take orders from you?
- No, I don't mess around
with you dog faces.
I'll be with the artillery observer.
You're getting your
artillery from the 442,
and he's never worked with them before.
- They're sending us up
without our own artillery?
Just the Japs?
- They're a good outfit, Culley.
Plenty good.
- Practically winning the war
single-handed from what I hear.
Japs.
- Let's get outta here, huh?
- Yeah, I could use a little fresh air.
- [Sam] You win, Chick.
- Japs in a Texas division.
Man, oh, man!
- Come here a minute.
Culley, they're not Japs.
- Huh?
- They're Japanese Americans.
Nisei, or, if you prefer, buddhaheads.
But not Japs.
They don't like it and neither do I.
- What are you, a Jap-lover or something?
- I said they're not Japs.
I'm warning ya, Culley.
- You're what?
- Warning ya.
- Lieutenant, that gold bar
looks real sweet on you,
but I do believe you're getting
a little big for your britches.
- I can always take the bar off.
- Any time you say.
(face punching)
(Culley grunting)
(engine revving)
- Okara!
- [Okara] Yo!
- Misoka.
- [Misoka] Here! Here!
- Nishigoka.
- [Nishigoka] Hey!
- No letters?
- Keep your pants on.
- Come on, snap it up.
- Kiri!
- [Kiri] Yo-ho!
- Kamakura!
- [Kamakura] Oh, here, here!
I take it!
- Cookies!
- Ikagani!
- Here!
- One cookie!
(men laughing)
- Hey, look!
How you like that, two sets.
I go see Masami!
Two sets.
- [Tommy] Sam, Sam, wiki-wiki.
- I'm wiki-wikiing as fast as I can.
Anything from my brother?
- No, all from relocation center.
Sugar report from Terry.
"Dear Sam, I hate to start
out a letter this way,
"but I think it best to get
the bad news over with first."
- Her cold, she no get better, huh?
- No, Terry's okay.
- Your mother been get sick?
Your father?
- It's my brother.
- He been lose his job on the farm?
Yeah, him and a couple of his buddies.
A gang beat them to a pulp
and said they'd lynch them
if they ever came back.
- Why they do that?
Why?
- Why?
Because they've got slant eyes.
That's a crime in some
places, didn't you know that?
How do ya like that?
We're good enough to carry rifles,
but we're not good enough
to pick sugar beets.
- Take it easy, Sam.
- Sure, sure, take it easy.
Take it lying down.
- Go on, beat it!
Blow off!
- Ain't I been telling you?
Suckers, that's what we are.
- Ah, chick, chick, chick,
chick, chick, chick.
- How would you like a dental appointment?
- Let's go, boy!
Katonk.
- Break it up!
If you're looking for a scrap,
you won't have long to wait.
We've been alerted.
Pull your tents down and
get ready to move out.
- Pull 'em down?
We just put 'em up.
- The men Lieutenant Grayson moved out
with have been surrounded.
- The whole battalion?
- What's left of 'em.
Grayson's okay so far.
Artillery observer got
hit and he took over.
- Just so the lieutenant is safe.
Him and his buddy.
- His dear old platoon sergeant.
- What's up with Sam?
- He just got some bad news.
- He's not the only one.
They're gonna send the new
replacements up on line
as soon as they arrive,
the batch my kid brother's in.
18-years-old.
(bombs exploding)
- Hey, Grayson!
- [Soldier] Medic!
Where's the medic?
- [Soldier] There he is!
Over here, Joe!
I found a full one.
- Thanks, pal.
- Give me a slug of that, will ya?
(bombs exploding)
- Hey, Grayson!
Look out!
- [Grayson] You okay, Culley?
- Where's that Jap artillery?
Where is it?
- Wildcat six.
This is Wildcat two.
Fire mission, over.
Fire mission point.
(bomb exploding)
Fire mission point,
Fox-Able-Easy-Baker-Mike-Charlie,
and point,
King-Sugar-Charlie-Love-Able-How.
- Wildcat two, this is Wildcat six.
Stand by.
One round smoke on way.
(speaking foreign language)
- Can't get a thing outta this one, sir.
- We got enough from the others.
Send him over to division headquarters.
(speaking foreign language)
- Get anything?
- Yes, sir.
Added to what we already know,
I can give ya a pretty clear picture.
- Good.
- It's all dense woods.
Those roads on the map
are just forest trails,
and Jerry has roadblocks on all of 'em.
The men are surrounded on three sides
by elements of the
338th Infantry Division,
the 198th Fusilier Battalion,
and the 202nd Mountain Battalion.
To the northeast--
- Well, let me see it on the map, captain.
- Well, starting here,
the Germans are dug in
on a continuous line
all the way around to here.
There's a gap here,
and one here that I know of,
but they're covered by
machine guns with interlocking fire.
There's a steep ridge here
that dominates this sector.
It's almost straight up on both sides,
and they have a strong
force sitting up on top.
- [Colonel] How far away from
here is the lost battalion?
- [Soldier] Well, I'd say 1,000 yards.
They're just about here.
- [Colonel] We'll have troops within
striking distance tonight.
(fire crackling)
- All right, Ohhara, this is your spot.
Good luck.
- Come on, shake a leg, will ya?
- This don't make sense.
Sticking our necks out for guys
like that buddy of Grayson's.
That sergeant, that's the kind
who ganged up on your brother.
- We get to the lost battalion,
that sergeant gonna change
his mind about us buddhaheads.
Plenty people already we change, eh, Sam?
Keeps up like Terry been writing letters,
by and by we gonna have it good.
You bet, yes, sir.
Good thing you read me letters,
or maybe I go get like Chick.
It's rough, it's plenty rough.
But we know what's it all about.
You bet.
More better we go for broke, yes, Sam?
- That's about it, Tommy.
More better we go for broke.
(wind rustling)
(bomb exploding)
- Ohhara.
Ohhara!
Is it bad?
- Million-dollar wound.
Luck of the Irish.
(wind rustling)
(bomb exploding)
- Medics!
Medics!
- [Soldier] Let's go!
- I'm glad you have someone to lean on.
I don't seem to recognize you.
Have you been back to any of the services?
- No, Father.
I'm not Catholic.
- You're not?
- Different kind of rosary.
I'm Buddhist, Father.
- I'll be here if you want me.
(bombs exploding)
(rustling winds)
(bomb exploding)
- We're gonna try to make contact.
(plane whirring)
The Piper Cub's calling
the shots for artillery.
They're trying to shoot
us in some rations.
- That'll be a big help.
Sukiyaki and rice.
- I could use another man.
- Well, the Piper Cub pilot
says there's at least
100 of 'em on this ridge.
And they'll be shooting
right down our throats
if we try to come up from either side.
Our engineers have been cutting
through a road on top of the ridge
so we can bring up a tank.
They're about here now.
But once that tank gets within range--
- When will that be?
- Hard to say, sir.
It's slow going.
(phone ringing)
Minefields all over the place.
- Tell division headquarters
I'm on my way back, will you?
(speaking foreign language)
- The Jerries have been
tapping the wires, sir.
Some of them speak perfect English.
(speaking foreign language)
- Wildcat three.
Wildcat three.
Sergeant Yasugomoto speaking.
(speaking foreign language)
Wildcat three, this is Wildcat four.
Come in, Wildcat three.
(speaking foreign language)
Wildcat three.
Sergeant Yasugomoto speaking.
(bomb exploding)
Wildcat three.
Sergeant Yasugomoto speaking.
(speaking foreign language)
- Good idea, sergeant.
- Thank you, sir.
It's just that good old Yankee know-how.
(speaking foreign language)
(metal clanking)
- [Soldier] Watch out!
(tree exploding)
- If I was a Jerry on
the end of this ridge
and a tank got close
enough to fire point-blank,
I'd take off like a ruptured duck.
- Yeah.
- Right over the side of the ridge.
- There oughta be somebody
down there to meet 'em.
- That's what I was thinking.
- Let's go.
- Hey, sergeant!
Sergeant!
Where's Lieutenant Ohhara's platoon?
- This is it.
- We're your new replacements.
Ohhara's the name.
Another suntanned Irishman.
- Come on.
Ohhara!
(bombs exploding)
(guns firing)
- They're Japs!
Hey, knock it off, will ya?
- What's the password?
- Dipsy doodle, that's it.
- That was it, a week ago.
- Let's have that password!
One.
Two.
(speaking foreign language)
Come on out!
- Make 'em give you the right password.
- You ever hear a Jerry try
to pronounce a Japanese word?
If that's not a buddhahead, I'll...
- [Soldier] You'll what?
- Sam, Chick, Tommy!
- A whole battalion's lost,
and we gotta find them.
- Man, I never thought I'd be
so happy to see a bunch of Japs.
Pardon me, Japanese.
I mean, Nisei.
No, that ain't it.
What is it, Grayson?
- Buddhaheads.
- [Culley] Okay, okay.
(guns firing)
- Buddhaheads, huh?
- That's right.
- He sure is touchy about that.
One time, he even slugged me.
- Slugged you, huh?
Did you hear that, Chick?
Where's the rest of
your outfit, lieutenant?
- Back there about a mile.
But it took us hours to get here.
On our bellies, most of the way.
- [Sam] When do we start?
- Not enough of us would
make it to do 'em any good.
- What do we do, lieutenant?
- That's up to you, Sam.
I'm strictly a liaison officer.
- [Sam] Skirmish line up the hill.
- [Culley] Skirmish line up the hill.
- [Chick] Skirmish line up the hill.
- [Solider] Skirmish line up the hill.
- [Soldier] Skirmish line up the hill.
- Tell me something, Sam.
What does (speaking
foreign language) mean?
- Well, freely translated: You're a heel.
A stupid jerk and a heel.
- That was putting it mildly.
- [Sam] Go for broke!
(guns firing)
(rustling winds)
(bomb exploding)
(guns firing)
(speaking foreign language)
(man screaming)
- Go for broke!
- [Soldier] Grenade!
Go for broke!
(soldier screaming)
- Look out, Tommy!
- Is that all there were?
- They went thataway, partner.
- [Culley] Go for broke!
(suspenseful music)
(grenade exploding)
(slow triumphant music)
- Yahoo!
(men cheering)
- Any of you guys want a cigarette?
- [Soldier] Bye, you buddhaheads!
- [Soldier] So long!
- [Soldier] Ride 'em, cowboy.
- [Soldier] Bye!
Thanks a lot, Jack.
- [Jack] See you in Berlin.
- [Soldier] Look out
for that mademoiselle.
- [Soldier] Take it easy.
- [Soldier] So long.
- Thanks.
(speaking foreign language)
- Goodbye, you all.
So long.
- I'll be seein' ya.
- Aloha, partner!
(men chattering)
(triumphant music)
(horn blowing)
- [Man] Battle honors.
By order of the secretary of war,
in the name of the President
of the United States,
as public evidence of deserved
honor and distinction,
the 442nd Regimental Combat Team
is cited for outstanding
accomplishment in combat.
The gallantry and esprit
de corps displayed
by their officers and men in bitter action
against a formidable enemy
exemplify the finest traditions
of the Armed Forces of the United States.
(upbeat triumphant music)
(dramatic music)